I said that because part of the process
are they a teror group
will can we why can't you say it watch
this this is absolutely incredible last
night he asked Jeremy Corman former head
of the labor party so in essence he's
there Bernie
Sanders 15 times whether he thinks that
Hamas is a terrorist group watch this
can we have a discussion can you call
them a terror grou can we have a disc
can you call them a Terr is it possible
to have a rational discussion are you
prepared to call possible is it possible
to have a rational you is it possible
come on answer that question you answer
it no it's my show you answer my
question you are the areass a terror
group listen can I are they a terror
group P can I speak answer the question
can I speak are they a terror group P if
you let me speak are they a terror group
if you let me speak I'll say something
go on then a ceas fire means both sides
you said that are they a terror group
listen I said that are they a terror
group process are they a Terr and
will can we go why can't you say it
peers can we go through what ought to be
happen just answer my question why do
you think are a teror in the world are
calling for a ceas a terror group come
on answer that me no not your show
you've got so many opinions why should I
answer yours when you won't answer mine
why do you give out your opinions all
day and every day you don't like aass a
terror group yes or no you won't let you
won't like it
on you what I've said is I've asked you
two questions should a mass stay in
power and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling and you wonder and you
wonder why people think you had a
problem with Jewish
people all right I sort of feel like I
have to apologize for showing you that
clip because in some ways that right
there like that version of television
and the way that debate has devolved is
sort of exactly why I started this show
and try to interview people the way I do
and communicate the way I do about some
of these important issues uh but yes 15
times here's Morgan asked him to just
say that Hamas is a terrorist group now
keep in mind this is the same question
that was posed to AOC in the halls of
Congress we showed you that and Rashida
Talib and ilhan Omar and they refuse to
say it so they don't think that a group
that breaks into someone's borders and
randomly with maximal violence and and
just like un Unthinkable evil
does all of the stuff puts babies into
ovens yes they did that and beheads
women and rapes people and goes to a
party and shoots as many people as
possible and throws grenades into
shelters to to MIM people I saw another
video I put it up this morning of of
some of that from October 7th I mean
it's just unimaginable but he just can't
say they are a terrorist group because
he is a Hamas supporter and he has been
for a long
time